la pauvreté des jeunes ont continué d'en
parler avec nos invités jean baptiste
eyraud porte parole de l'association
droit au logement et la syrah à gagny
professeur de sociologie et
d'anthropologie à l'université paris
viii c'est notre débat de ce soir
bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation pour le comité
d'experts présidé d'ailleurs parole
l'ancien patron de renault louis
schweitzer
il y a urgence il faut un revenu minimum
pour les jeunes tout de suite qu'en
pensez vous nacira guénif oui on ne peut
qu'aller dans le sens de la pop était
autant que ce qui concerne milieu
étudiant
nous observons depuis des années
dégradation des conditions d'études et
des conditions de vie qui sont
extrêmement limités précaire incertaine
et le fait que par exemple à paris 8 où
j'enseigne à près de 80% des étudiants
qui sont des étudiants travailleurs donc
cette idée que les étudiants où la
jeunesse voudrait un travail de personne
n'a attendu
l'exhortation de bruno le maire pour
chercher un travail
ils travaillent déjà et ils sont déjà
précaire dans le monde de l'emploi
donc cette proposition permettrait de
lever une pression extrême qui
aujourd'hui s'exerce sur les étudiants
et les étudiantes et qui fait qu' ils ne
peuvent pas ne peuvent pas se consacrer
à leurs études dans de bonnes conditions
un siècle aujourd'hui deux s'appelait de
personnes jean baptiste eyraud est-ce
qu'il faut un revenu minimum pourra
aller les jeunes de 18 à 24 ans tout de
suite
évidemment évidemment il faut absolument
sortir les jeunes de la précarité
thierry dans laquelle il s'enfonce
aujourd'hui et pas que les étudiants
d'ailleurs connaissent aussi la
précarité tous ceux qui ont acquis qui
font pas des clichés qui bosse à droite
à gauche qui cherchent des petits
boulots et qui ne trouvent pas puisque
dans la restauration dans le tourisme
dans l'hôtellerie qui était qui sont des
secteurs économie
que qui ont poids les jeunes beaucoup et
bien là il ya plus de boulot donc on a
une situation qui s'est dégradée
et j'ajoute que il ya aussi une
précarité qui s'est renforcée avec la le
renchérissement des prix du logement
le logement est de plus en plus cher en
france les loyers ont augmenté et donc
les jeunes ont d'énormes difficultés
pour se loger sont contraints souvent de
rester chez leurs parents d'autres d'une
part et d'autre part ils vont peut-être
trouver pour certains des colocations
débrouiller pour faire des colocations
contrainte c'est à dire que c'est pas
forcément envie situation qui est très
favorable
et puis n'oublions pas qu'elle
gouvernement sabre aussi dans les apl il
a commencé par une réforme en 2017 a b c
d appel de 5 euros on s'était justement
sur le logement des étudiants mais vous
préciser tout à l'heure qu'il fallait
évidemment à une aide pour les étudiants
mais pas seulement pour les étudiants
c'est ce qui est prévu apparemment
nacira guénif en matière des critères
d'attribution
ce comité d'experts il propose que ce
soient les mêmes pour les étudiants et
les non étudiants ce qui inclurait en
fait dans ce dispositif les bourses
le système des bourses
et au final le comité d'experts propose
une prestation sans sous condition de
ressources au total ça coûterait à peu
près entre 5 et 7 milliards d'euros par
an cela vous semble viable au pont bien
je crois que le quoi qu'il en coûte qui
a été proclamée l'année dernière au
moment du début de la pandémie sur
l'impact majeur sur la société française
aujourd'hui a plus que besoin d'être
appelé oui absolument il faut mettre en
place un revenu qui ne soit pas
conditionnelle qui permettent à la
jeunesse française de s'assumer sans
avoir le sentiment d'être dépendantes ou
d'être en quelque sorte minorée et ça
doit se faire quoi qu'il en coûte 7
milliards d'euros je pense que c'est une
somme qui est tout à fait raisonnable
lorsqu'on regarde aujourd'hui quel est
le coût comme peu dégagée par rapport à
d'autres secteurs qui ne sont qui ne
contribue pas autant qu'il le devrait et
ça ne devrait pas être un problème de
dégager cette somme pour en quelque
sorte se mettre au service d'une
jeunesse qui est l'avenir de la société
française et inclure les le système des
bourses ça ne poserait pas de problème
dans ce dispositif
non je pense que la difficulté qui
pourrait se poser c'est que les bourses
ne sont pas très élevées en france je
pense qu'il faut arrêter de croire que
les bourses permettent aux étudiantes et
aux étudiants qui les perçoivent de
vivre avec vous on sait très bien que
les étudiants boursiers souvent ou un
emploi d'appoint donc diminuer le rsa en
fonction de la bourse perçu il faudrait
trouver un équilibre qui ne pénalise pas
les étudiantes et les étudiants
boursiers ça c'est important
on vient au logement puisque vous êtes
vous même le porte-parole de
l'association droit au logement
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
l'ajustement pour aider
les plus jeunes à s'en sortir à ce
niveau il ya ce dispositif qui est
proposé ce qu'il faut d'autres mesures
en plus en supplément d'un côté oui il
ya un petit oubli justement sur cette
question du logement parce que d'abord
les jeunes ils ont besoin de quitter le
foyer familial quand ils en ont un
on a observé que des sans abri sont en
fait des enfants de la date ce qu'on
appelait la dass c'est à dire sans ils
sont jetés et sont jetés à la rue a tout
bonnement à partir de l'âge de 18 ans et
on va les retrouver
surtout si on trottoir à faire la manche
est bon pour une bonne part dans donc là
il faut absolument aussi agir alors
maintenant sur la question du logement
d'une part il faut que les ape bien sûr
il faut arrêter toutes ces réformes là
qui ont pour objectif d saurait les et
les locataires en particulier les jeunes
et qui leur interdisent d'accéder à un
logement aussi maintenir ensuite il
faudrait également agir sur les niveaux
de loyers qui sont trop élevés en france
et et 15 mois quand j'étais jeune je me
suis logé sans difficulté gvt est la
location logement
je me suis levé j'ai trouvé l'équipe you
de bob etc ou bien je me suis j'ai
trouvé des solutions pour le g sans
difficulté majeure est donc hors
aujourd'hui séparés car quand on est
quand on est jeune avait non pas les
parents derrière ont payé logements
commencés dans la vie active
on n'a pas trouvé le boulot d'aminata
rémunérateur suffisant la galère pour se
loger et on est logés dans des
conditions très très difficile donc pour
nous il faut agir aussi sur cette
question là pour les étudiants bien sûr
beaucoup d'entre eux aujourd'hui
connaissent des situations de très
grande pauvreté de très grande précarité
et pour les jeunes en général ceux qui
sont sans abri mais aussi ceux qui sont
contraints de rester chez leurs parents
ou de cidre eu d'autre solution a ses
règles et donc le logement apparemment
c'est un oubli de ce dispositif
problème quand même
l'exécutif n'est pas vraiment favorable
à un revenu minimum pour les jeunes à
une aide sèche d'ixelles en tout cas ils
préfèrent des mesures d'accompagnement
couplée à des indemnités comme l'aide à
l'embauché les emplois aidés la
formation est-ce que c'est efficace ça
ou utile ou pas jusqu'à présent c'est
vrai c'est vraiment étrange qu'on
continue à vouloir appliquer les mêmes
méthodes qui ont déjà prouvé leur échec
et laure et leur inefficacité enfin la
question l'accompagnement à l'emploi ça
fait 20 ans 30 ans qu'on en parle je
rappelle que nous sommes dans un chômage
structurel en france est qui et qui
évidemment percute de plein fouet
d'abord la jeunesse
lorsqu'on sait que en france un jeune a
du mal à trouver un emploi parce qu'on
lui demande d'avoir de l'expérience ce
qui est antinomique avec le fait
d'entrer sur le marché du travail
ce sont les mêmes problèmes qui
continuent à produire les mêmes
solutions qui ne marche pas donc je ne
comprends pas que l'on soit encore à
parler de mesures d'accompagnement
lorsqu'on parle d'une génération entière
de la société française qui doit assurer
l'avenir de ce pays dans une compte dans
des conditions de transition écologique
dans des conditions de discrimination
qui sont complètement diffusé partout
dans la société dans des conditions de
formation qui sont de plus en plus
précaires et avec des étudiants qui
aujourd'hui enfin enfin arrêtons ces
mesures qui sont des cautères sur des
jambes de bois et qui ne n'affronte pas
la réalité de la précarisation
croissante de la jeunesse je pense jean
baptiste eyraud est ce que vous pensez
que le gouvernement avec ce rapport les
conclusions de ce rapport peut changer
son fusil d épaule
alors je n'ai malheureusement je suis
pas très optimiste parce que la tendance
lourde depuis 2010 c'était même un peu
même avant gap laissé se creuser les
inégalités voire encouragé aggravation
des inégalités les ménages les plus
riches gagnent de plus en plus d'argent
les bailleurs et gros bailleurs sont de
plus en plus riches et
voilà et produisent tous un produit de
la misère puisque cet enrichissement se
fait sur le dos des classes populaires
des jeunes justement des étudiants de
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui arrivent dans
la vie active bien n'ont pas le profil
on va dire pour pouvoir trouver trouver
un emploi voilà vous connaissent une
situation de handicap
bon je pense que c'est les classes
populaires c'est ces ménages aux revenus
modestes et c'est les jaunes voilà c'est
aussi de cela quand il faut aujourd'hui
s'occuper à la fois pour revenir bien
sûr on l'avenir de la société mais aussi
pour jeudi rétablir une cohésion sociale
traduit tant d'autres pays à mesure que
se creusent les tensions les clivages
les faux procès je pense à cette affaire
ces attaques obscène qui a contre 9
aujourd'hui également ses lois
liberticides répressives comme celle de
la loi sécurité globale qui est en train
de sortir et d'autres lois
malheureusement il nous attend et qui
vont encore creusé creusé les diviser
les français et la population les
opposer les unes aux autres qu'il
pratique relativement logique si vous
voulez dans un dans un venant d'un
pouvoir qui il est enrichi une petite
minorité qui est l'expression de
minorité la plus puissante et la prison
le temps c'est un autre débat peut être
une autre fois merci en tout cas à vous
jean baptiste eyraud porte parole de
l'association droit au logement et la
syrah yéniches professeur de sociologie
et d'anthropologie à l'université à
paris vite merci d'avoir été avec nous